[Music]
stanford university
today's class session is on the future
of medicine we have tim mills joining us
here today quick context is that we've
seen some pretty incredible innovations
in medicine over the last 50 years these
include eradicating smallpox learning
how to transplant organs even creating
artificial hearts and in the past year
alone we've been able to develop
multiple vaccines to cope in 19 and
we're going to be exploring today some
of the recent advances in medicine and
also what the future holds for us quick
background on tim he's currently
managing director of the venture capital
fund sanderling ventures sanderling for
those of you who don't know is one of
the oldest venture funds in the
biomedical space it was founded in 1979
he has over 25 years of experience in
venture capital investing corporate
management product development and
biomedical research he's participated in
probably i think the last count i had
was over 20 companies i'm sure that
number just constantly keeps increasing
every single year with various different
areas such as biotherapeutics medical
technology personal health care
he's served a number of roles prior to
joining sanderling ventures this
includes being corporate vp of new
business development and also chief
scientific officer of target
therapeutics which was a medical device
company that was acquired by boston
scientific for a little over a billion
in 1997. he's held a number of other
roles on the business side most
significantly in business development
and advanced research development and
finally he's also held a number of roles
in academia including roles at uc
irvine's medical center uc san
francisco's radiology department and
stanford's bio design and spark programs
tim thanks for
joining us again for this class tim is a
class favorite in terms of discussing
the future of medicine we'll start by
discussing some of the recent advances
um in medicine as it relates to cobin 19
ai and ml especially with alpha fold as
well as crispr and then we'll talk about
a few other topics so thank you tim
well thank you so much you know i really
enjoy and find this an honor to be able
to be part of this i think the future of
medicine we are at a unique time where
our future
is real
in that i think we're going to see
massive changes
we've learned in the past 20 years more
about our human biology
than we have and i think collectively
all the years before that so i think
that you know we are
coming through a kind of a wormhole of
trauma that has happened to us over this
past year you know we were saying when
we first joined the call today that a
year ago
if we would have said that you know we'd
be
in the same maybe not boat but maybe in
the same water a year from now
i don't think any of us would have taken
that bet but we certainly are at this
point
um not that much further from where we
were before but we've learned a
tremendous amount that
stress i think will you know irrevers
irrevocably change the way we think of
health care the way we think of the need
to be prepared and to allow us to
venture out into new areas really that
we hadn't ventured out before so i'm
excited uh to meet with you all again
today and and share some thoughts
so we have been in a global pandemic in
the past year coven 19 and unlike last
year's class now we have vaccines
developed for coven 19. can you share
some of your thoughts on the topic in
terms of how fast these vaccines were
developed should we be concerned about
how fast they were developed or how does
this really
affect how we think about treating
future infections
well i i think i see it as all extremely
positive
maybe with one caveat and what's
positive about this is if you think
about the two leading
vaccines the pfizer vaccine and the
moderna vaccine both are an mrna
platform
and the beginnings of these platforms
were really motivated from the initial
and i'll just use the term sars one
infection
that you know didn't really impact the
us that much it was probably more
impactful
in canada as far as north america but if
you run the clock back on that that was
2002 2003
so
what is you know what i think we were
very fortunate to have happen was they
were really call it
17 16 15 whenever you start counting
years of activity that allowed these
platforms to really mature now you know
the moderna platform was really sort of
a combination development done with
support from the nih and then the pfizer
vaccine was really came out of primarily
a very
brilliant husband and wife out of
germany i'll just call it a biotech
startup
and
and yet
the the nidus of these thoughts
came from very different places
their end results and their platforms
are
spookily
similar
and i i think there's absolutely nothing
to worry about in those platforms in
fact you know
if you think about it we gave him 17
years to figure it out so i think time
was basically on our side the platforms
are incredibly potent and flexible the
ability to take basically the genetic
sequence of the virus and within 40 to
50 days have a vaccine ready to go is is
not because they cut corners it's
because they had the
platform the plug-and-play platform
ready to go so
i think that not only
is that great for getting us sort of out
of this pandemic but i think it it sheds
a kind of a new light
on how we should be thinking about
viruses and just say pandemics in
general and and how important it is to
have flexible platforms you know you
would say well you know why didn't why
weren't we able to do this for just
standard flu vaccinations you know we we
struggle every year with coming up with
the right sort of anagenic profile and
then they grow the flu vaccines and then
they get them ready and then by the time
people are getting their shots in the
fall you know it's already the wrong
strain of virus but you know i would
just say that you know
need is the mother of invention right
and and when you have
an extreme need like what was really
delivered by sars one and and luckily
sars one in some ways was more deadly
than than covet 19 and that's why it's
one of the reasons why
it was able to should be be shut down
and quarantined the way it was but i
think we're i think because of this
stress and because of of this need this
extreme need we're in a much better
position now
and and the the last piece of this is
really
a barda you know barta is an
organization
that the government and all taxpayers
support and up until now barda had
always played what i thought was a very
passive role in the pandemic preparation
and i'm hopeful
that now after what we have all lived
through that hopefully barda takes a
much more
proactive approach and keeps the proper
stockpile and technologies and helps
support those
not just you know giving you
wishful thinking as a startup company
that maybe barta will buy something if
you basically raise all the money and
develop everything for some other
indication
and i'm hopeful that that changes and i
think that we have good reason to
believe that it will
tim i'm glad you mentioned mrna as the
basis for the pfizer and modern vaccines
could you talk a little bit more about
that and specifically are we going to
see this technology now apply to other
infectious agents like ebola zika and
influenza is the as you term
need out there for that
yeah
well yeah so so first i mean and this is
just i think we all do you have any sort
of scientific background or or
perspective
i mean everybody should be tipping their
hats
to these scientists physicians
and staff members who were part of this
development because it really is
brilliant science they were clever
enough to look at the way
uh normal protein synthesis is done
and
basically you know
as as we talked about in last year's
class
do do a biological hack
and come up with something that could be
used for a very specific indication so
if you think about a little bit about
your genetic biology
normally you know messenger rna is
something that is created through a
transcription process basically using
the dna in the nucleus of the cell
to create
a copy of some portion of that
genome and in that copy then finds
itself or transports itself through the
transcription process and gets beyond
the nucleus so it penetrates or let's
just say evolves to
living from inside
the
nucleus to outside the nucleus and the
cytoplasm and then you know the the
normal progression from there is is that
genetic material becomes the blueprint
of the protein that is now going to be
grown that has functional whatever it is
right for functional resistance to
bacteria viruses or just functional
activities within that particular cell
but these researchers were so br we're
so smart they said well
why don't we come up with a way that we
can
put
what looks like messenger rna from
outside the cell into the cell but don't
mess with the nucleus because we know
that you know we start messing with the
nucleus and
you know you just open up more degrees
of freedom of potential problems with
genetic miscoding but
we can come up with our own messenger
rna equivalence and put that into the
cell into the cytoplasm and then let the
cellular engine
work and and you know to think about
how you would sort of even imagine that
you could do that let alone do it and
albeit you know like we said they had 17
years to figure it out but nonetheless
it is brilliant and it is extremely
effective and so
what you know the covid was
perfectly teed up for this a
plug-and-play activity so they got the
the genetic the genome of it they they
looked at and used their sort of
virology expertise and decided you know
we don't want to be too specific on the
way we encode this but we want to find
what we believe will be physical
characteristics of the virus that will
be unlikely to change through the
initial mutations and so this corona or
this physical structure was was and is
the piece of the magic sauce here that
makes all this work so well and so
i think that not only is this going to
help us find our way through this
current pandemic
but i also think you're right it will be
used for other because there's no reason
why you can't use this same cellular
engine to create other things that you
need in the body and if you look
you know in the moderna if you look in
theirclinicaltrial.gov
activity they have two programs both in
phase two both one is in melanoma
and the other is in cmv cardiomegaly
virus and so
i am sure that
if either one of those
turns out to be positive which you know
i think they've got a pretty good shot i
mean those are both tough tough
indications but if either one of those
shows positive signs then they have i
believe a handful or so of other
clinical trials that are currently in
phase one but yes i think this will open
the door to using this
really elegant science to do other great
things to treat disease
another big force change from the
covenant 19 pandemic has been telehealth
i'm curious on
your thoughts on how did telehealth
evolve during this pandemic
what's your prediction on the future of
telehealth are there some major
regulatory hurdles that we still need to
overcome
well you know isn't this interesting
because this is that you know the mother
of invention question right
up until this need there was so much
pushback on telehealth even though
telehealth seemed
like inevitable right i mean for for at
least a decade we've been seen probably
you know i would just say in our in our
adventure firm dozens
of what i would call credible
telehealth type of
applications
but they were always they would always
get hamstrung on something like you know
hipaa violation or this or that and so
it was very difficult who's going to pay
for this was you know another question
but it is funny how all those or let me
put most of those roadblocks
got all knocked down because we were at
a point where we didn't want to or at
least didn't believe we should be seeing
patients in the hospital setting and if
there was any way to do it outside the
hospital we were going to move mountains
we were going to allow considerations
that before were see seem to be
insurmountable to suddenly vanish and
and i think in the long run this has set
us up to have a much better health
system in the future i mean one medical
if you if you any of you are familiar
with that company
perfect timing for one medical one
medical is run by the ceo of one medical
used to be the ceo of the stanford
health systems is a young brilliant
individual who kind of sees the need to
have kind of
disassociated small at-home types of
interactions which i think are which we
have thought for a few maybe at least a
decade maybe some smart people saw it
coming two decades ago uh the need and
and the and the absolute reality that
will happen and so you know what i think
is the very fact that we're having this
meeting instead of all you know
congregating somewhere on the stanford
campus is an indication that there are
things that have changed that will never
be the same i'm not suggesting we won't
have this class in person someday i hope
we do but that's the least of the
concerns right i think that what this
does is this sort of kicks open the door
and i think that where the real
opportunity in telehealth is is to start
coming up with real
sensors where you can do
fairly elaborate things in your home
that you would never even think about
doing before because there was always
something in the way somebody was going
to claim a you know hipaa
compliance issue or nobody was going to
be willing to pay for it or you know it
wasn't going to be a cpt code for the
physician blah blah blah
but i think that i think that is behind
us now and i think what's really there's
no i think the only limit ahead of us is
how much technology can we develop what
kinds of tests can we do in the home
setting
i mean what kind of pictures can we take
what kind of measurements can we make
how can we get biological information
from your home so that you could make a
full diagnosis and you know have your
medicine brought to your house in a
drone i mean you know it's not out of
the question so i think that these are
the kinds of
questions that will be answered now
because they'll be potentially venture
capital and other
capital willing to risk it because of
the the potential payouts and the
benefit to the patient
another hot recent advancement in
medicine is ai ml and alpha fold quick
context is that a few months ago there's
a google-owned ai research company
called deepmind which claimed to have
solved the 50-year grand challenge of
accurately predicting the structure that
proteins will fold into
so alpha fold is an ai program that was
developed by deepmind which performs
predictions of protein structure tim can
you share your thoughts on this
breakthrough and why is this so
important why should we care about this
advancement in science yeah
so let me try to give you an analog
first of all this is amazing as well i
mean and let me give you the analog
there was a time
back
when
the brightest minds in the world were
trying to understand how electrons
flowed through semiconductor materials
and
you know this young kind of brash
engineer scientist that was working for
bell labs in new jersey william shockley
patented this new invention that he
called the transistor
and the transistor
was as revolutionary
in some degrees
in its time versus what the standard of
we'll just say electrical engineering
was
which were things called vacuum tubes
that had a anode a cathode and a base
and and what they would do is you
controlled the output of these devices
by proportionally controlling the input
and
these technologies were mirrored or
mimicked
by
these semiconductor devices but it
wasn't until shockley kind of put it all
together that you could build these
things and then
the horse was out of the barn
people were trying to do bigger and
better integration of
transistors
but they struggled because they didn't
have a simulation tool
that
was able to
use form to predict function
and
and so
what happened was
there was a graduate student and a
professor at cal berkeley
who came up with
the characterization of
and just think of it as the electron and
whole mobility proportional to
electrical field sort of think of it as
perpendicular to the direction of
current flow in the semiconductor and
they built a simulator called spice
and the acronym is really you know
something like
a simulator for integrated circuit
electronics and
that
revolutionized our world the fact that
we have a calculator you remember the
early hp calculators that had more
computer power in them than you know the
first computer that nasa had to track
the
first mercury a manned space launch in a
handheld device run on batteries and and
look how far we've come from there look
at the the the multi the multi levels of
development that's that's going on since
then in microprocessors in signal
processors digital signal processing the
only reason we can do that is because we
can build arrays of electronics arrays
of transistors that's really what drives
all of this stuff is high density
packing of transistors that can be
characterized and simulated
and so
that has changed our world
to a point where we're not even really
aware of that technology anymore
and i in this situation with alpha fold
i think is
as revolutionary
and potentially even more than that
because the biological world
is more
uh complicated
than the three-dimensional world or
maybe four dimensions
when you think of current flow within a
semiconductor device and transistor and
high density for for microprocessors and
other things and what they were able to
do is they were able to basically create
and predict from the form of a protein
what its function is going to be and in
this case the folding of it is is its
function and so
you can think about this in several ways
but
ideally
you can think about the way you could
look at diseased proteins
and you could
see how they are folding compared to
what the non-disease protein should be
and then using the prediction model you
could work it backwards and you could
find out where the defect is and to be
able to
either do genetic modeling or
pharmaceutical modeling or electro
modeling many different ways to then get
in there and fix the problem
now that's on the therapeutic side but
what i think is equally interesting
is that if you could
in the biological world predict function
through form
then you could go one step beyond that
and you could say
i can predict form
from the genome
so if you got to the point where and
this is kind of the next direction that
this work
that they'll be going with this work
that you could basically
identify the genome
you know the base pair combinatory
double stranded helix you could you
could define that and that that in the
it has a lot of analogs in the spice
model of transistors you put in certain
characteristics that would be like
loading the genome in
and then you press the button you run
the simulator and you get not only the
the form of what it's going to look like
but also the function
and if you could do that then well let
me put this away when we can do that
then you'll be able to design drugs
you'll be able to do
medicines from you know we'll just use
the term medicines because there'll be
lots of different ways to intervene at
that point but you'll be able to not
only treat disease but hopefully
eradicate diseases
throughout all all the different
phases of human life
so it's a big deal
that's fascinating on how alpha fold can
affect our understanding of diseases
medicines drug discovery on the topic of
ai and ml there's been a lot of
discussion on
ai and ml's use case specifically in
medicine healthcare as it relates to
possibly replacing healthcare workers
with
ai and ml algorithms what's your view on
this issue what are your thoughts on the
future of that are there obstacles that
we still face for the implication of ai
and ml in healthcare
well
look
ai and ml
are
just an extension
to the way we are interacting with
machines and the way we are using
let's call it
microprocessor based systems that can be
programmed or programmable based systems
to help us
be better
at everything that we do
and medicine
is
you know no stranger
to
needing to do things better i mean every
year there's some new technique that
comes out
to make knee surgery better every year
somebody's trying to figure out how to
grow articular cartilage to make repairs
in orthopedics better every year people
are trying to figure out how to cure
cancers that you know continually elude
us
every year
we you know lose elderly patients to
debilitating dementia so there is plenty
of things to do
and so not only is healthcare a great
and fertile arena for the implementation
of ai and ml but it will only make the
lives of the practitioners better think
about how silly that that thought is and
i'm not suggesting that it's silly that
you mention it you are you are speaking
what you hear a lot of people say well
gosh
isn't this going to reduce the number of
radiologists who need to review pap
smears you know blah blah blah blah
well the bottom line is it will make
their life much better it will make
everyone's life much better because
they'll be able to do more they'll be
able to do more for at a lower cost
they'll be able to do more better and so
at the end of the road if you think
about other technologies that that have
entered the field did the field of
electrical engineering get reduced
because we now have circuit simulators
no it didn't in fact they are just able
to simulate better and more circuits and
develop more products based on that when
the when the uh stethoscope was invented
instead of taking a stick and putting
the physician putting the stick in their
ear and putting the stick against the
patient's chest when they came up with a
with a stethoscope did that did that
make it so we had to we didn't need as
many physicians to listen to you know
chest murmurs
no it absolutely did it made them better
at what they do
and i'm a firm believer that this
technology this specific technology is
not going to disenfranchise anyone in
the medical field but it's going to make
their ability to treat disease better
faster and cheaper another recent
advancement in medicine crispr very hot
topic could you briefly describe to us
what exactly is crispr how does it work
why is it crucial to gene editing
diagnostics what are the major use cases
just kind of a brief introduction of
what exactly this is yeah sure well
again
another incredibly fascinating area and
again you know a beautiful science the
way everything has come together and if
you think about it i mean the crispr
technology in its simplest mode is
a powerful tool for editing the genome
and
you know
crispr i mean people throw throw the
name around what does that stand for it
stands for clusters of regulatory
interspaced short palindromic repeats
and so what does that really mean when
you look into the genome
and the best way that i sort of think of
it is it's a
it's a unique
characteristic of the genome almost like
the way a song is written if the song is
written and it only had one verse
then if you tried to edit that verse you
could potentially get everything messed
up
but because
of this and of this
acknowledgement or i guess scientific
discovery
that there are these clusters of regular
reg
regularly interspaced
short palindromic repeats
then the
song has multiple verses that sort of
repeat
maybe slightly different words
it repeats again but this structure is
unique and this is the thing that's
powerful
that you're able to
to find that these specialized regions
within these repeats of dna
that have two distinct characteristics
the presence of a nucleotide repeat so
think of it as these different verses to
the song
and and spacers so that you can actually
you can define the end and the beginning
of these repeats
and so
the the discovery continued and it was
the next piece is as is as critical is
the fact that the song has
uh different verses
but there's an enzyme called cast nine
so the the the shorthand of crispr
you know the name is really crisper cas9
and and this is special the crisper the
the palindromic repeats have specialized
stretches of dna and then the protein
cas9 is an enzyme that you can imagine
acts like little scissors to go in
it matches with this dna code maybe like
you know
20 20 different base pairs or so and
then it finds through that matching it
finds where
the stretches of dna is and then the
cas9 is is an enzyme that cuts
cuts through both strands of the dna
and then you have this
thus you've been able to effectively
edit the genome and now you need to
to fix that if you just let the body do
its own thing and you cut that chunk out
it's likely to
not heal itself the way you want it it's
likely to create a mutation in in when
it heals but
the the second real breakthrough was
that they were able to
fix by filling in that gap with a
sequence of nucleotides and so
you just imagine you have a short strand
of dna as a template and that you could
write in any gene that you want or
correct any mutation
so
it was really an identifiable
discovery
that the genome has these
songs in it that have multiple verses
you can use
this gn this dna template of what you
want to where you want to remove the
problematic dna
the cast enzyme
cuts through both
strands
that piece comes out and then the back
filling or the healing with writing in
any gene that you want to correct the
mutation allows for the editing sequence
to be extremely powerful now
you know why why has crispr you might
ask why is it you know is everybody so
worried about it well
think about that mechanism that i just
described is when you go in
and you are you've created this special
dna piece
that is
complementary to the the genes that you
want to edit
remember if that sequence of genes or
that verse of the song shows up anywhere
else in that animal's genome
chances are this is going to edit that
spot too right because equal probability
so where crispr works best is where you
just have
i mean ideally one location of this of
this mutation
and so i think that
that's one of the issues as we look
forward where will crispr be used first
it'll be used in areas where at least i
think it'll be used in areas where this
material that you're taking out really
only shows up in you know at best one or
very few places so that when you do this
edit you're going to edit all the places
that it shows up you want to have it
only affect the pathological dna that
you're trying to remove and not remove
something that you wish you had thanks
for providing us with that overview and
it sounded like you were touching a
little bit on some of the ethical
barriers as well could you dive a little
bit more into the ethical challenges
also regulatory challenges for further
development of crispr
right so and let me just try to put an
umbrella over these because they they
are many and the real issue is
people don't want two things to happen
one they don't want to have mutations
come out of the process and make the
patient worse than they are
and the other the other part is that's
on kind of one extreme the other extreme
is they don't want a functional benefit
to then follow with some unwanted or off
target characteristic change that could
happen later in life right so
i think that
what's likely to happen is that
if you target
some of these diseases that we believe
at least currently
that they're more
single foci of their problem like as an
example but i i think you know sickle
cell disease or thalassemia anemia
diseases like that are believed at least
currently to have
their
if you want to call it a mutation i
would call it their their you know
problematic dna more resident in fewer
places within the genome and so i think
that
the regulatory concerns for those for
that type of work i think will be much
more doable as
assuming the science continues to point
in that direction
if if the science of whatever the
disease is that you're going after
sort of teaches otherwise that you want
to cure you want to change the color of
someone's eyes from blue to brown and
you know by the way
you're going to put the patient at risk
for a whole host of other things down
the road then the regulatory you know
approval would be insurmountable you'd
never get that done
so there are technique modifications
that are going on as we speak to make
these systems better and better and
better you know the
the one of the concerns is that the
efficacy of this editing is not a
hundred percent
and the off target effects or just call
it mutations are not zero
so
that's why there's concern and i think
it's appropriate but it's also
again a science that i believe
can be regulated in a way that we could
treat some of these serious well i i i
believe the blood-based disease are
where where they should start and and
could start in that area
and you know just imagine how powerful
this would be is if you could eradicate
sickle cell disease or thalassemia i
mean to me that's worth
giving it a shot now
just for full disclosure we have a
company in our portfolio that's using
crispr in a slightly different way
and this is i think well the jury's out
because we don't have it perfected yet
but we have a company that we basically
are trying to treat type 1 diabetes by
putting eyelet cells
back into the patient and you and you
might say what do you mean back into the
patient well these are eyelet cells
that we grew from
uh not cadaver transplants but from stem
cells fully functional eyelid cells and
currently we put them in a like a bio
reactor a small bioreactor and we place
this underneath the skin and the
bioreactor is there to keep the body's
immune system from attacking
the islet cells because eyelid cells
were made from human uh cells and so you
know they have an anagenic profile that
is not necessarily the host and so
that's not good and the bioreactor is
there to try to compensate for that now
in addition to the bioreactor cells
which once they're in the reactor you
know theoretically doesn't matter if
they have antigen profile or not but we
would like
to be able to improve the growth of
those cells and be able to work through
a more porous bioreactor so we're we are
in the process of using the crispr
editing techniques
to essentially
not change the function of the eyelet
cell for you know diabetes or glucose
regulation but to basically be able to
strip off
the antigen profile so that in a sense
the cell has no
has no signature back to its initial
cell or cell type and that it could be
transplanted into patients of all you
know of all types of all genetic
material types without being seen as
well as being seen as as the host tissue
so i'm sure there will be other
technologies that will use crispr and i
think that the simpler the edit the
better and the simpler the edit i think
the simpler the regulatory hurdles will
be tim thanks for discussing those
recent advancements in crispr alpha fold
ai ml covered vaccines mrna i have a few
other questions on emerging technologies
this one's from the class what are your
thoughts on the anti-aging space what
life extension technologies and
rejuvenation methods excite you the most
if at all and i'll let the student who
asks that question also jump in with
additional commentary
yeah i'm sort of just curious like you
know what therapeutics you know you
think are the most interesting is it
like you know analytics or perhaps other
you know sort of interventions you know
like stuff around you know metformin or
other sort of drugs i'm curious what
your thoughts are there
well i mean
the area that is probably the most
interesting to me are the synalytic
drugs and it's probably just because
i know the least about them right the
concept is very intriguing that you
could somehow identify let's just call
it these non-dividing
cell types and remove them
and in doing so
regenerate
rejuvenate
the host cell and get it to function
more normally i think again
that hypothesis is alluring right
now
as we've started to go down that path
we have i think been both encouraged and
discouraged and so
the the issue is that
the
let's call it handful
of product
that has been studied are mostly
uh natural product right natural product
or things that look similar to small
molecules and so the the problem was
with small molecules is they're not very
typically they're not very specific in
their targeting so small molecules have
the unfortunate side effect of
off-target responses and of course the
off-target responses always raise their
ugly head as you start to
increase the dose of the drug
and that is
kind of what at least
that we are
what we've seen as we've studied some of
the different compounds that have been
tried to use here now the flip side of
that is
natural products usually
don't have well usually it's probably
wrong word but oftentimes don't have
off-target effects because they've sort
of evolved over time to do certain
things however
they've also evolved over time to have a
very
narrow
dose curve and when i i refer to the
dose curve is a curve that allows for a
dose to stay in suspension to work
within the normal biological parameters
in the in the organism and what
typically has happened with these and
again it's a handful of
uh different natural products is
to get them to function in in the way
that you know that this sort of let's
just call it classic analytic compound
needs to function the doses have to be
increased and as and when you start
messing with the natural products dose
normally what happens and this is what
has happened in most of the experiments
that we've been involved with is
you can't keep them in suspense you
can't in other words they become
undruggable and so
i i've been both excited and
disappointed in this but i think it's
certainly an area
that we are trying to better understand
and try to understand how we can learn
and potentially support some activities
to try to learn in this area because
at least the premise or the thesis is
very very
interesting that if these
non-dividing cells are getting in the
way
of a more vibrant
cell type understanding how to extract
that and get back the normal function
that's intriguing
another question from the class is
related to nano technology and the
question is how do you think
nanotechnology will impact medicine is
it realistic to imagine nano robots
helping to repair damage in our bodies
on a cellular level if so what is the
time horizon for such inventions that is
a great question and i i think
20 years ago this whole concept of
a nano robot that could go into the
coronary artery space and basically
slowly but over time
remove arterial plaque remove blood
clots i mean this seemed to me
to be something that would happen in our
lifetime
now
in parallel with those thoughts and
developments as time went on
our basic understanding of biology
has continued to improve and so now
i think that maybe what we're really
going to see are biological robots
biological systems that have more of a
physical mimic to them
where their interaction instead of
having a little just imagine some kind
of nibbler
that cruises around and looks for
coronary artery plaque that we have a an
infusion that a patient gets you know
once every three months and it has a
lytic solution that is carried in a
we could call it a nanoparticle or a
liposome particle that is attracted
because of different chemical
characteristics to the plaque and and or
the ruptured plaque where the where the
blood clot is and and and that i would
call that a biological machine i think
is probably more likely in our future
and it's not really
because the the nano machines didn't
work it's just that the biological
systems you get energy for free if you
can make that work because they're
living in a s in us in a soul and a
solute
of energy and
and having that energy
is something that you know has always
hamstrung nano machines because it's
difficult to come up with solutions to
that need tim i have one final question
as it relates to emerging technologies
and this is regards to neuralink so last
week on the new social app clubhouse
elon musk talked about near-link and how
they've already been able to get monkeys
to play video games maybe a tough
question but how close are we to having
chips implanted in our brains
well you know i would love to and maybe
elon's watching so you know give me a
call tell me tell me the answer and i'll
report back to the class so
i really don't know but it's extremely
exciting and and the notion of how will
the man machine interface evolve over
time i think absolutely we will have the
opportunity to do those types of
physical modifications
to help link us
into our computer world or electronic
world or virtual world and so i don't
really have the insight
into how they're doing there with the
monkeys but
i do have some insight into this area so
the this is about 10 years ago gsk glass
glaxosmithkline
had a very interesting
patent i would say sort of roundup they
they took all their drug development
subsidiaries and parent company
and they looked at
what they were doing that affected
nerves right i mean a lot of drugs that
we take don't necessarily affect nerves
they affect solid organs they affect
other components of the of the body
enzyme releases but what they did was
they put these all these together and
then they they filed a
broad ip around many of them
and the idea was
that
instead of thinking of treating disease
using pharmaceuticals
think about treating the disease used
using electroceuticals
and so
the electroceutical assumes that you can
do something to the nervous system you
know in our simple uh minded approach
with at least i do i think of nerve
interaction as
neuromodulation of some kind
maybe you ablate a nerve maybe you make
the nerve conduction faster through some
way or you make it slower through some
way
but this whole notion of of
electroceuticals
so and a man made
interface
into changing the way
the nervous system responds in the body
and
with the idea of glaxosmithkline knows
because they developed a bunch of drugs
that affect the nerves for certain
diseases they knew exactly what those
diseases were they knew the nerves that
they were impacting et cetera et cetera
and they were out shopping it around to
venture firms and for us it was
interesting but overwhelming because it
was so big and they didn't want to break
it up into little pieces there were
certain pieces i was very interested in
but they wanted somebody to take it all
and at the time the only group that
really kind of had the wisdom and
and the stomach for it and the money was
google or and and they at it is now part
of their verily franchise and they have
partnered with gsk and are working on
these electroceuticals and so
there is no doubt in my mind that this
will cross over elon's concept
is very viable
and i think
gsks and virili's concept are very
viable there are ways to talk and read
off axons and there are ways to
communicate to the outside world and
there are ways to
treat diseases but it is not for the
faint of heart and so some of the early
work that i saw
proposed for
human to computer interaction were as
simple as
either implanting or having on you know
like the google glass you'd have an
accelerometer either in your glass or
underneath your skin
and you basically because it could
detect
motion in your head you use the
accelerometer as really a joystick to
doing certain things now that's a long
way
from what at least elon has proposed
they want to accomplish and certainly i
think a long way from where the
accomplishments will ultimately become
but it is a super exciting area
and i think in our lifetime we will
definitely see an improvement in the way
we interact with our virtual electronic
universe